[音楽]
皆さんこんにちはこんばんは
えーと今私は誰もが行きです今は地域活性化と多文化共生を交流した取り組みをして
おります本日はよろしくお願いします
します
大丈夫ですか
さてちょっと話を進めていきたいと思うんですけどもみなさんあーちょっと最新私の話
をちょっと聞いてほしいんですけど一生懸命てかっこいいですよねー
[拍手]
ありがとうございます
一生懸命てかっこいいですよね本当に一生懸命なところがめちゃくちゃカッコいいと
思っているんですよ
とにかくかっこいいめちゃくちゃカッコ一生懸命が
話がわからない
一生懸命がわからない
おやセット仕方ないなぁあの
米かっこいいがあると思うんですけど例えばあ床はサッカーが出来てカッコイイとか
100点が取れてカッコイイとか色々なかっこいいがあると思います
皆さんてないがかっこいいっていうのは丸までがかっこいいってのはありますか
行け目がかっこいい
ねーっ
そういうのはまああのあなた自身がカッコいいっていろいろとあると思います
かっこいいって基本的に他の自分が他の人に対して優れていることを指していることは
なんじゃないかなと思いまして
でも話せばいいですか
z 4話だと思いまして
基本的に
ようやく来たんですけど
あの
かっこいいっていうのはまああの基本的に指標の一つになるじゃないかなというのは
思います
だから皆さんって切っお野菜ねちょっといろいろハプニングがあったんで
つきましたありがとうございますあの基本的にカッコいいってあの子がかっこいいって
いう感じで
まあ自分が自分よりも他の人が優れているときに使う言葉だと思いますいやばそれは一
つの指標ですよねその指標というのはみなさん正直な話かっこいいって言われたいです
よね
言われたいですよねうんありがとうございますうなずいてくれてありがとうございます
あの機能的になる言われたいと思いますでもだいたいそういう時って自分の格好よりも
周りの終わりが出しているかっこいいに従って動いていると思うんですよ
でそういう時ってだいたい損だと思いませんか例えば iphone とエールが出た
としましょう
の iphone てればあなたにとってとても層しかないものです
なぜな今あなたは iphone 入れ棒を持っていてこれを買ってもあまり良いこと
がないから
損です
でも周りの人たちとか tb とかで iphone てる最高です皆さん買って
くださいこれ思ったらかっこいいですよっていう洗練アウトしましょう
で家族の人たちが iphone とリブ使い始めました性がかっこいいからあなたは
どうしますか
使えますか
高江
高いまだ値段のこと言ってないんだけど
そうだよね今言える持っててやる刈った草しかないよね
高いもんねでも皆さんに合わせるということはキリがないんですよ
ちゃんとしろまたサーティーン出たらまた買うよね
は買えますよねポーてぃんで誰かいますよね周り合わせていくってことは
キレイがないんですよ
だからこそ自分の中でしっかりとした目的を持って自分は今 iphone 7を持っ
てて iphone といえばが自分にとって良いことだからいいというメリットが
あるものだから買うという目的だったら
自分の中でしっかりしているから iphone テープで買うだけ進みますよね
みんなで合わせるよりもこれからの現代社会
みんなに合わせていくっていうのも確かに必要です別に僕は自分の中でしっかり守って
犯罪をしろとは言ってません
自分の中でへ
しっかりと目的を持って活動していくことがこの先求められるものがあります
しっかりと自分で主観を持って活動していくことそれがこの先将来で活躍するには必要
なものです
でもでもですよなかなか長続きしませんよね
例えば痩せたい
痩せたい皆さん痩せたくてダイエットして最高な日続きました
1年続いた人いますか
すご
米じゃない僕三日坊主ざっぴーよと思ったんですけどだいたい
られたとか自分で衣装もはっきりしてやるものってなかなか長続きしないんですよね
だから確かにマイケル
自分の中でしっかり判断を持ってやることは必要なことだとわかったんだけどさ
長続きしねえんだよどうすりゃいいんだよマイケルっていう時にこそ一生懸命がかっこ
いいっていうのを
私は提示したい
みなさんわかりますか
自分の中で一生懸命ってやるのがかっこいいっての私は提示したいんです
まず一生懸命ではカッコいいっていうのを一生件について説明していきたいとおもい
ます
一生懸命とは一生をかける命と書いて一生懸命です
命とは日本の固有表現で物事のことを指しますつまりどういう事かあ今死んでもい次
死んでもいいっていうか
5今までの人生をかけるつもりで一つ一つもの事にかけていく
それが一生懸命であるということです
この表現は英語では直よくできない日本固有の表現となっています
だからこそ一つ一つ一生懸命やっていくっていうことが命をかけてこの後死んでもいい
やって思うくらいにまじめに取り組んでやっていこうと一生懸命だと思ってください
理解したうえで次の話に行きますで一生懸命はカッコいいって具体的にどうするの
かっていうのを説明をしていきたいとおもいます
まずステップは何事も一生懸命に尽くしてください
さあ皆さんにがと苦手なことがあったり苦手な人が入ったらなかなか言い訳をすると
思いますねっ
怖いおじさんがいたら声をかけようとは思い思わないですよね
思えないもんね思えないですよねでもそういう時に自分の中でこの人にかけたいという
確実な意思があるんだったらその直感に委ねて行動してみてください
何事も一生懸命にやってほしいとまずはまずは第一歩
でも大体こういう時って失敗したらどうするのさ
このだらどうするのさいっぱいそんなことを言う人がいると思います
そういう時に step 2です
過去の自分と競ってみようこれはどういうことか
たとえ今自分が失敗したって次の自分は乗り越えばいいじゃないか
仮に今自分が過去の自分がころんなんだったらその失敗がなんで失敗したのかを
分析して次乗り越えればいいじゃないかということです
失敗は成功のもとって言いますよね
それがとても大事ですでもこれってこの失敗が一生懸命やった結果の失敗じゃなかっ
たらわからないんですよ
手を抜いて失敗したんだったらわかりようがないじゃないですか
だからまずは一生懸命やって失敗したら失敗したで次の自分のリカバリーしていけば
いい
苦手なことがあったふと前に立てなかった
まずは一言喋ってみよーかんでしまったじゃあ次の瞬間は一生懸命やって噛んでしまっ
たんだったら別の方法でやってみようじゃないかと
そういう感じに考えてください
もうここの基本的にこれは自分の中でずっと繰り返しやっていくことなのでとても緊張
するしとても馬鹿にされるし多くの人から笑われてすごい子立南決めになります
見たくなる時もあるでしょう
3時に自分が神したかっこいいお
その格好いいという判断に従ってください
周りがどう言おうと
自分がかっこいいんだから自分がかっこいいと思ってるんだからそれでいいじゃあり
ませんか
今あなたがやろうと思ってあなたが信じられないものだったら何か信じられるんですか
その活動
自分でかっこいいと思ってるんだったら
ずっとその意志を信じて突き進みましょう
これが一生懸命がかっこいいという考え方の真髄です
ぜひ皆さんにも
この考えを
見つけて欲しいなって思ってここになっています
私のちょっと経験を話させてください
私はもともと今ここに立ってますけどものすごく昔はあがり症でそれこそ人前に立っ
たらもうこういう感じでうロボットみたいに動いてどうもみなさんこんにちはどうも
だるまマイケルって住みたいな
すごい
かみかみで何も言えなくてでも目立ちたくて
でも目立ちたい
だからこそみんながやっているようなことを試すんですそれがカッコいいと思えるし
皆と同じように原稿を完璧に覚えて完璧に入って
でも歌っ合わないそういう時に一生懸命がかっこいいという言葉に従って
みんなとみんなの道から反対したことを歩んだとしても自分がやれる
一生懸命がカッコいいこれがかっこいいって思ってるんだったらそういう月住もうと
思ってまずは原稿を捨てた
原稿を覚えることは自分に向かないって思ったから
次に一歩1前に出ようと思ったその方がもっとみんなにに
の顔が見えると思ったからそうやって自分が最初は人前で一言も話すことすらでき
なかった少年が今こうして皆さんの前で
ねっ
ちょっと緊張しながら話しています今ものすごく楽しいし2階ここで僕が一生懸命やっ
た結果
失敗したりしたとしてもまた明日とかあさっきの自分がそれをリカバリーして別にどこ
で生かしてほしい
そういうのが今の僕のスタンスです
だから皆さんもぜひ一歩踏み出してみませんか
一歩を踏み出してみてまずは
過去の自分よりもカッコよくなりませんか
そしてもう一歩
自分だけの未来を切り開いていきませんか
そうやって自分の未来を切り開けたら最終的にもう一歩
誰かの背中を押していきませんか
それが僕の一生懸命がかっこいいという考え方です
では最後にせっかく一生懸命がかっこいいということを皆さんに教えたので皆さんと
一緒に掛け声をして終わりたいなと思います
僕が一生懸命はって言うんで皆さんかっこいいって言ってくださいね
練習いきますよいきますよ一生懸命は
[音楽]
これの3枚渡しますよね
きますよ今最後い細胞いきましょう一生懸命は
まっこえー
以上ですありがとうございました
[拍手]